[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
hay conmoción por el asesinato del
embajador de italia en la república
democrática del congo look atanasio
murió después de recibir varios disparos
en un ataque armado contra un convoy de
naciones unidas en el que también
fallecieron su guardaespaldas y el
conductor del vehículo
en níger se realizó la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales en medio
de la esperanza de lograr la primera
transición pacífica y democrática del
poder sin embargo siete integrantes de
una comisión electoral perdieron la vida
en esa misma jornada cuando su vehículo
pisó una mina terrestre
y en noticias de alcohol 19 varias
naciones aplicará ya avanzan en sus
jornadas de vacunación y varias de ellas
gracias a donaciones o aportes del
gobierno chino el gigante asiático se
acerca a los países subsaharianos
analistas consideran que el país
orientales tienen sus propios intereses
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y comenzamos
en la república democrática del congo
donde fue asesinado luca atanasio el
embajador de italia en ese país africano
el diplomático falleció en un ataque
contra un convoy de naciones unidas en
la ciudad de goma en el este del país
reportes locales indican que el
conductor y el escolta del diplomático
también fallecieron y otros integrantes
del convoy resultaron heridos desde la
comisión europea rechazaron este ataque
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en roma' natalia mendoza
quien desde italia nos dio más detalles
del contexto en el que se produce este
asesinato pues por el momento lo que se
sabe es que el ataque tuvo lugar a unos
10 kilómetros de la ciudad de goma esto
es en la zona este del país el embajador
se encontraba a bordo de un vehículo que
hacía parte de un convoy de dos
automóviles del programa mundial de
alimentos al parecer estos automóviles
no iban escoltados por militares y
cayeron en una emboscada hombres armados
asesinaron primero al chofer
es al guardaespaldas y finalmente
hirieron gravemente al embajador quien
murió posteriormente en un hospital
cercano el ataque por el momento no ha
sido reivindicado pero se sabe que en
esta zona operan varios grupos armados
de la república democrática del congo
níger cerró las urnas de votación
después de desarrollar la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales tras
las que se espera se produzca la primera
transición democrática de poder en la
historia de este país propenso a los
golpes de estado la votación se vio
empañada por la muerte de siete
trabajadores electorales locales cuyo
vehículo aplastó una mina terrestre el
candidato oficialista mohamed bazoum fue
anunciado como ganador de esta segunda
vuelta con el 55 75 por ciento de los
votos según los resultados finales
provisionales publicados por la comisión
electoral independiente sin embargo la
proclamación oficial de los resultados
podría tardar varios días el anuncio
estuvo marcado por un clima de tensión
en la capital niamey donde cientos de
personas se manifestaron en las calles
con palos y armas blancas quemando
llantas en las carreteras para expresar
su rechazo a la victoria de la sum
veamos cómo transcurrió la jornada
electoral
una elección que enfrentó a dos pesos
pesados de la política mohammed razón
mano derecha del presidente saliente de
níger y mamá neus mané quien se
convirtió en el primer líder
democráticamente electo del país en 1993
antes de ser derrocado en un golpe de
estado tres años después este domingo
los votantes de la capital nigerina
esperaban que el resultado de la
votación fuera ante todo uno la paz
yo he elegido a quien quiero que dirija
mi país
todo lo que quiero es que estas
elecciones sean pacíficas tranquilas y
completamente transparentes y de la
tracción total
sin embargo níger se encuentra en estado
de emergencia desde 2017
mientras lucha contra las insurgencias y
hadise estás que se han extendido desde
malí nigeria inestabilidad que hizo eco
en esta jornada con 7 trabajadores
electorales muertos en el occidente del
país luego de que su vehículo chocara
contra una mina a principios de enero
100 ciudadanos murieron tras un ataque
a dos aldeas cercanas a la frontera de
níger con malí miles de soldados fueron
desplegados en todo el país para la
votación de este 21 de febrero que
marcará el inicio de un traspaso
pacífico entre presidentes electos por
primera vez desde la independencia de
níger de francia en 1960 sólo 7,4
millones de los 22 millones de
habitantes del país eran elegibles para
votar se esperan resultados no más de 72
horas después del cierre de las urnas un
pequeño avión de la fuerza aérea
nigeriana se estrelló a las afueras del
aeropuerto de abuya debido una falla de
motor matando a siete personas que iban
a bordo así lo informó la fuerza aérea
nacional el avión se estrelló mientras
regresaba al aeropuerto de abuya después
de informar de una falla en el motor en
ruta a mina las autoridades abrieron una
investigación del caso
un nuevo secuestro masivo en el norte de
nigeria al menos 42 personas fueron
secuestradas por un grupo armado no
identificado y un estudiante fue
asesinado tras un asalto a un internado
en la ciudad de [__] en el estado de
níger 27 de los secuestrados son
estudiantes
nigeria es un país fuertemente golpeado
por la violencia terrorista de boko
haram y en el pasado ya ha vivido
secuestros masivos similares a este
un nuevo secuestro masivo golpeó a
nigeria hombres armados irrumpieron en
un internado raptando a 42 personas y
asesinando a un estudiante y ala exacto
llorando a dios estamos orando a dios
para que sean liberados pronto estamos
llamando a la policía para brindar más
seguridad para que no vuelva a suceder
la zona donde se produjo el secuestro es
acá gara en el noroeste del país un
lugar donde no tiene presencia habitual
boko haram pero si suele sufrir ataques
terroristas todavía no se sabe nada de
los desaparecidos y ningún grupo
insurgente se ha atribuido la autoría
las autoridades han desplegado efectivos
militares para intentar recuperar a los
afectados
hemos pedido al gobierno federal que
despliegue todos los recursos mientras
buscamos todas las opciones para
garantizar el regreso seguro de las
víctimas de los incidentes
los secuestros son una práctica habitual
en el norte de nigeria aquí
boko haram un grupo fundamentalista
islámico está en guerra contra el estado
nigeriano el 11 de diciembre 344
estudiantes fueron raptados en la región
de katsina aunque seis días después la
mayor
ellos fueron liberados su secuestro más
conocido quizás sea el de 276 niñas en
abril de 2014 la noticia dio la vuelta
al mundo y aunque más de un centenar de
ellas consiguió huir o fueron liberadas
todavía hay decenas en paradero
desconocido
y hablamos ahora el coi 19 porque en
medio de la carrera global por las
vacunas contra esta enfermedad los
países pobres han sido los más
perjudicados a la hora de adquirir dosis
algo que afecta principalmente al
continente africano en esta situación
llama la atención el papel de china que
ha sido la principal potencia en dar
prioridad a la distribución de sus
vacunas en el continente algo que muchos
creen que es una forma de poder blando
en la carrera global por la inmunización
colectiva contra el kobe 19 hay un claro
perdedor áfrica el acaparamiento de
vacunas de los países ricos ha hecho
casi imposible a los estados africanos
acceder a las dosis pero en este
contexto ha aparecido una potencia que
ha encontrado una oportunidad china
chin está trabajando con 58 países en la
asistencia de vacunas y también está
trabajando con unos 22 países en la
adquisición de vacunas
países como zimbabue recibieron una
donación de 200 mil dosis y otros como
senegal nigeria guinea ecuatorial o
marruecos han empezado a vacunar gracias
a las dosis de scinopharm y si novak los
países africanos las han elegido por
varios motivos china las vende a precios
bajos y son mucho más fáciles de
conservar que otras como las de facer
bayón tech o modernas el interés de
china en áfrica se ha incrementado en
las últimas décadas por medio de
inversiones en salud o infraestructuras
a cambio de recursos y muchos creen que
este gesto es un paso más para
fortalecer la llamada ruta de la seda
sanitaria en áfrica además de los
acuerdos bilaterales china se convirtió
recientemente en uno de los principales
donantes del programa de la onu kóvacs
a pedido de la omct china decidió
proporcionar 10 millones de dosis de
vacunas a kóvacs principalmente para las
necesidades urgentes de los países hoy
desarrollo
este esfuerzo de china podría mejorar su
imagen en estos países frente a
occidente y reforzar una red de alianzas
en un mercado con inmensas posibilidades
para beijing
[Música]
empezó en kigali la capital de ruanda el
juicio por terrorismo contra paul
rusesabagina el ex gerente del hotel
milk colin que saltó a la fama gracias a
la película hotel ruanda como refugio
para centenares de personas durante el
genocidio de 1994 años después se ha
convertido en uno de los principales
críticos del gobierno del actual
presidente paul kagamé su papel como
héroe ha quedado en entredicho veamos
fueron 1.200 personas las que se
refugiaron del genocidio de ruanda de
1994 en el emblemático hotel de 1000
colin en kigali sugerente paul
rusesabagina fue aclamado como un héroe
en todo el mundo ahora es uno de los
principales críticos del gobierno de
paul kagamé pasa era recepcionista en el
hotel en 1994 y asegura que la
reputación de roces a vagina es
exagerada rusia estaba llena de sets doc
deshaceros y un lodo de efectivo y
llenos y rusesabagina usaba víctimas del
genocidio para hacer negocio les robaba
todo su dinero
[Música]
y pase eso hacer que el míster pasaba su
tiempo de fiesta con los soldados que
estaban matando los tutsis fuera del
hotel y luego llegaban al hotel para
celebrar jefe de la fed los suárez de
excluir al hotel él niega estas
acusaciones fuera de ruanda muchos
supervivientes del genocidio todavía le
agradecen por salvarles la vida pero el
gobierno la acusa de traición abriendo
una guerra de narrativas
phillips no te here is the hero made in
hollywood supervivientes del genocidio
no lo ven como un héroe es un héroe
hecho en hollywood nos traicionó vendió
su historia para hacer dinero juntos
fundó y financió grupos terroristas y
estos grupos terroristas han atacado a
ruanda que la está actuando rusesabagina
acusa a kagamé de crímenes de guerra y
se ha convertido en un enemigo del
estado mientras que el gobierno lo acusa
de terrorismo lo arrestaron en agosto
cuando regresaba desde dubai
expos y usó la plataforma de hotel
ruanda para exponer violaciones de
derechos humanos que el gobierno de paul
kagamé todavía comete contra la
población
son para el parlamento europeo firmó una
moción para pedir una investigación
internacional sobre estas confusas
circunstancias y para que tenga un
juicio justo
y finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con música que nos llega
desde uganda donde rehmán a mácula se
consolida como una de las voces
femeninas más importantes del país
[Música]
recientemente la cantante presentó su
nuevo sencillo titulado this is love en
compañía de artistas ruandés de penn con
un videoclip lleno de romanticismo una
mácula pone el afrobeat de hecho en
uganda de las listas con más
reproducciones el del continente
africano así finalizamos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días ustedes pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom amigos más adelante
con más información que desee esto es
france24
[Música]
debido a mi causa
qué
[Música]